If you've seen Thor: Ragnarok, you may think
that the movie left Goddess of Death Hela's
situation pretty clear cut.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and before I go any further, here's your spoiler
warning if you still haven't seen Ragnarok
yet, because today I want to look at some
of the clues in the film together with Marvel's
plans for Thanos, plus Hela's comic book history
to theorise why there's a good chance we'll
see Hela back in Avengers: Infinity War or
Avengers 4.
And just to let you know, I've got a couple
of Marvel giveaways running at the moment,
so keep watching this video for more details
of how to win.
Let's start with the first clue that Hela
could have survived that giant sword strike
from Surtur.
There's an especially relevant moment earlier
in Thor: Ragnarok that hints at Hela's incredible
power and near-invincibility.
After she arrives on Asgard, she takes out
the Warriors Three, as well as a slew of elite
Asgardian fighters in an incredible display
of her skills.
At one point, though, she gets stabbed in
her back all the way through to her front
with a sword.
This kind of stabbing would be enough to kill
or at least severely wound any less powerful
character, but Hela just carries on fighting,
taking out all the remaining soldiers.
It's a detail that happens very quickly so
you might not have taken it in fully the first
time round, but it demonstrates that what
would be deadly to many barely seems to leave
a scratch on Hela, indicating she has superhuman
durability in the MCU as she does in the comics,
and possibly also regenerative powers.
Interestingly, VFX supervisor Jake Morrison
said that when they designed Hela's costume,
the script detailed that she had to get stabbed
in the suit and then the suit had to heal
around it and also her cape had to absorb
bullets.
On that last point, it's worth noting that
Hela is wearing her cloak in this scene with
Surtur, which we also know from the comics
has an important effect on her powers.
Speaking of Hela's powers, when she revealed
the true history of Asgard beneath Odin's
mural, you could see a painting that showed
she originally wielded Mjolnir and, before
that, we also saw her shatter Thor's mighty
hammer, which as Odin once said was "forged
in the heart of a dying star".
In other words, Hela's power is incredible
in Thor: Ragnarok and Thor realised that even
he plus the other Revengers could not defeat
her.
OK, you say, but a stab from an Asgardian
sword isn't the same as the absolutely enormous
sword that Surtur brought down on Hela.
And no, it isn't, but intriguingly at the
moment that Surtur brought his sword down
on Hela, a bright oval-shaped light surrounded
her, which seems a little curious.
Hela, like Doctor Strange, has the power of
teleportation and can open portals to instantaneously
move to another part of the universe.
She arrived in Norway in that manner and,
if she was fast enough, she may have escaped
Surtur this way too.
And, again, Hela is still wearing her cloak
when she's struck by Surtur, and if you look
really carefully, it seems like she could
have been using her cloak to shield herself
against his attack.
On top of that, we never actually see a real
close-up of Hela's apparent demise, likely
because Marvel realise they have a good villain
here and therefore they don't won't to lose
her for good or they have other plans for
her already.
Now, I kinda like the idea that Hela either
escaped or that her powers are such that she
could have survived that takedown by Surtur,
meaning that she's floating around in space
somewhere.
But let's just assume for a moment that, despite
all those powers, the combination of Surtur's
sword and then Asgard exploding was too much,
and that Hela did die.
Well, the thing is, of course, these are comic
book movies, so if the creators want to, Hela
can be brought back, as has happened before
in the comics.
Something else to consider is the Eternal
Flame, which could be useful in resurrecting
Hela if she is dead.
When Hela entered Odin's treasure vault, she
referred to the Eternal Flame as "true power"
and she used it to resurrect Fenris Wolf and
her undead army, plus Surtur was resurrected
via the Eternal Flame in order to bring about
Ragnarok.
In the comics, the Eternal Flame can't be
extinguished, and with Thanos turning up on
his Sanctuary 2 ship in the mid-credits scene,
I wonder whether he could have picked up the
Eternal Flame, assuming it's still burning,
together with Hela's body.
And putting the two together, we could get
a resurrected version of Hela.
Or could Thanos use the Soul Stone, which
some fans see as being connected with the
Eternal Flame, to bring Hela back to life?
Next, we need to talk about Thanos and why
he's a big part of the reason Marvel may bring
back Hela.
I think we can look at these two characters
as soulmates of sorts.
They're both megalomaniacs whose ambition
it is to conquer the universe.
Remember that in Thor: Ragnarok, Hela revealed
she was frustrated with Odin when he decided
to rein in Asgard's empire once the two of
them had conquered the Nine Realms.
In contrast to her father, Hela wanted to
carry on and conquer the entire cosmos.
Bringing Hela and Thanos together would be
a deadly combination as they'd form perhaps
the MCU's most twisted and lethal couple.
And it's worth noting that Hela and Thanos
actually got together in Marvel's current
run of The Unworthy Thor comics.
Now, I can see that Hela and Thanos share
a twisted view of the universe, but despite
multiple cameo appearances so far, we still
don't know exactly why Thanos is collecting
the Infinity Stones, other than a somewhat
generic thirst for power.
Perhaps that's all it is, but what if he already
has a connection with Hela?
I mean we know Odin kept Hela banished while
he was alive, but we don't know if Thanos
was aware of her ultimate fate and her conquests
alongside her father before that.
But if he was, it's not inconceivable that
he might have felt a kinship with her and
would have wanted to gain enough power to
impress her or try to break her out of her
prison.
And for the final piece of the puzzle we need
to go back to the original source material.
Earlier this year, when Kevin Feige was asked
about Thanos's motivation, he wouldn't commit
to anything too specific, but he did say that
Thanos's motives will be similar to those
that he has in the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
in the comics.
To recap briefly, in the comics, Thanos' desire
to wield the Infinity Gauntlet is tied up
with his desire to impress the character Mistress
Death, who he adores.
And he uses the Gauntlet to obliterate half
the population in the universe for her.
And, if you think back to the mid-credits
scene in the first Avengers film, it seems
like this has already been hinted at, as at
the end of that movie, Thanos responded with
a smile when he was told that 'to challenge
[humans] would be to court Death'.
The Infinity War trailer at D23 and Comic
Con showed Thanos wreaking large-scale destruction
and I wonder if his motivation is because
he's trying to prove himself to the Goddess
of Death, Hela, and to get payback for what
happened to her in Thor: Ragnarok.
I think Hela would be a great substitute in
the MCU for Mistress Death from the comics
as Hela is an interesting character who's
already been established, and that means Marvel
don't have to introduce yet another character
in the third and fourth Avengers movies, which
are already overflowing with characters.
Of course, you may still be sceptical about
Hela's return, and it may still be that the
supervillain really is dead and gone for good,
however, when Marvel and Cate Blanchett were
asked about the possibility of Hela returning,
they were pretty coy.
Marvel Studios producer Brad Winderbaum has
said that Hela is one of the best villains
Marvel has ever had and has confirmed that
she represents all the things that Thanos
values.
And Cate Blanchett herself hasn't ruled out
returning to the MCU as Hela either.
I also wonder whether some scenes with Hela
have already been filmed for either Avengers:
Infinity War or Avengers 4.
After all, reshoots for Thor: Ragnarok took
place in Atlanta which is where filming for
Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers 4 took
place, so it wouldn't have been too hard to
secretly film some scenes with Cate Blanchett
and Josh Brolin, who plays Thanos, on a set
with a reduced number of crew.
Perhaps a post-credits scene for Avengers:
Infinity War revealing that Hela is actually
still alive?
Now, that would be an end-credits scene to
remember!
So, what do you think about Hela returning
to the MCU?
Would you like her to team up with Thanos
in Infinity War or Avengers 4?
Or do you have any other theories on why Thanos
is trying to collect all the Infinity Stones?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and make sure you also subscribe for
a chance to win some cool Marvel merch.
I'm giving away a Thor: Ragnarok Funko Pop
and also a very cool Obsessed with Marvel
book by Titan Books, and I'll be announcing
the winners on my upcoming Justice League
videos.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget hit the
thumbs-up button and also check out some of
my other Thor Ragnarok videos on all the movie's
deleted scenes plus more great theory videos
by tapping the screen right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!